and do you think Cedric that having a
little humiliation in your life as a kid
prepares you for not as a stand-up but
like as a human yeah I think so I mean
you know I mean kids because kids gonna
go to school and they they get pulled by
you know their their peers and stuff so
I think if you know if they if at home
you get a little bit of ragging and you
learn how to play the dozens a little
bit in a fun way sure you can go to
school and not be like everything was
you know you were bullied by every
little thing you know question do you
ever make jokes that um are a little
kind of bad dad jokes
you stand by everything no no
I definitely have some jokes that you
know like don't go over well like I mean
but but I I I don't know the bad dad
jokes I love the one about uh my
favorite ones like the the days on the
calendar I I feel sorry for them because
their days are numbered oh God yes
that's
like that oh I'm taking that house yeah
I'm not feeling that one